one second no we said no wrong I went to
number one and you went down the tubes
Rand Paul shouldn't even be on this
stage she's number 11 obviously I'm
doing pretty well at number one in every
polls by a lot is visceral response to
attack people on their appearance my
goodness that happened in junior high I
never attacked him on his look and
believe me there's plenty of subject
matter right there Carly listen get it's
rough there would be else on the stage
guy throughout me I say not in a
braggadocious way I've made billions and
billions of dollars okay so I just want
that on the record I started listening
to Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan and
Reagan Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan you
didn't answer my question
the only answer I heard to the question
I asked is that you would you would
reach out to Vladimir Putin 40 years ago
I smoked marijuana
if they can't declare war on Iran
Republicans can at least move forward
with their war